thanks for watching this video
my name is Junior I am a PhD student at
Stanford University
in this video I'm going to tell you
about our recent idcs paper
beyond the worst case budget visible
mechanism design
this is John work with my advisor
Aviator Rubinstein
let me start by introducing the problem
setup
in budget Facebook mechanism design
there's a single buyer who has a budget
b
and there's Market I
there are n sellers in the market
the seller has an item
and this item has a value V and the cost
C
value V is public information which is
known to the buyer
but it's cost C is private information
which is only known to the seller
himself
for example here we have a fish market
and the buyer who is a chef
he knows the value of the fish from his
experience
but he doesn't know the true cost of
this fish to the Sailor
the goal of the buyer is to is to
procure the items from the market in
order to maximize his total value
moreover we make a large Market
assumption that is the cost of each item
CI is at most little o of B
the goal of budget feasible mechanism
design is to design a mechanism that
decides which subset of items to
purchase for the buyer
and specifies the payments to the
sellers
a mechanism has to satisfy two
constraints
first
the sellers should be incentivized to
honestly report their costs
second
the total payment to the sellers has to
be within the budget
note that if both value and cost are
public information then it becomes The
Cask knapsack problem
instead of formalizing the precise
definition of a mechanism
let's just do an example to give you a
better sense
for Simplicity let's assume every item
has the same value but unknown cost
consider the following mechanism which
is called clock auction by installer and
the Jeep
first we initialize an offer P to be the
budget b and we need to initialize the
number of remaining sellers M to be the
number of sellers n
as long as P times m is above the budget
b we decrease the offer P slightly and
we ask each remaining seller to leave if
their cost is above the offer
and we update m
we continue doing this until P times m
is at most the budget b
at its end we pay each remaining seller
p and give their item to the buyer
it's easy to check the sellers are
incentivized to behave honestly
specifically if at any point during the
mechanism
the cost of a seller is above's offer
then there is no incentive for the
seller to stay because even if he stays
there is no way for the final payment to
be able to cover his cost
moreover the total payment is always
within the budget
because of the wire condition
now we have seen an example of mechanism
but how should we create the performance
of a mechanism
recall the problem instance is specified
by a budget b and the market I which
consists of the values and costs of the
seller's items
if both values and costs are public
information then we can think of I and B
as an instance of network problem
therefore a standard performance measure
for mechanism is worst case competitive
ratio
the worst case competitive ratio is a
value achieved by its mechanism on the
instance in B divided by the optimum
value of the nav sub instance INB
and both I and B are chosen by the
adversary
the clock oxygen which I expand a couple
slides ago achieved one-half of worst
case competitive ratio and a nice result
by anoree go well and the next art shows
that there is a mechanism that achieves
one minus 103 worst case competitive
ratio
and they prove woman's wrong already is
the best we can get
this worst case optimality result is
very nice
but does the worst case optimality
indicate that the AGM mechanism is a
better mechanism for practice
unfortunately we find worst case
optimality doesn't generalize to typical
case
consider the following extremely simple
instance
there are n items they all have the same
value and the same cost one
the buyer's budget b is equal to n
for this instance
it's easy to check the clock option will
converge to a payment 1.
and it extracts the full value of this
instance
however it turns out the AGM mechanism
only extracts a one-man's only fraction
you might say this instance is too
special
consider the following more realistic
instance
there are 1000 items they will have the
same value but their costs are sampled
from a natural distribution
and we fix the budget to be twenty
thousand
the following table shows the expected
fraction of the full value which AGN
mechanism and the clock oxygen achieve
respectively for various cluster
distributions
such as causing distribution uniform
distribution exponential distribution
the gaussian mixtures
we can see that for all these
distributions AGM mechanism consistently
get close to one minus one over a
fraction
but the clock auction can do much better
therefore it's natural to ask can we get
the best of both words
is there a mechanism that not only is
the worst case optimal but also performs
favorably on every instance
by performing favorably on every
instance I mean the mechanism has to be
as good as a large class of mechanisms
on every instance
but which class of mechanisms should we
consider as a benchmark
at least we want to discuss to contain
clock auction in the AGN mechanism
the most ambitious class is obviously
the class that contains all the
mechanisms
in the next slide I will explain it is
unreasonable to compare to some
non-uniform mechanisms
so we will compare to all the uniform
mechanisms for now
informally a mechanism is uniform if
every seller is facing essentially the
same distribution of offers
for example in color correction
essentially every seller is facing
exactly the same offer
which is the payment that clock auction
converges to in the end
an AGM mechanism is also a uniform
mechanism
in this slide I wanted to explain why it
is unreasonable to compare to all the
non-uniform mechanisms on every instance
first let's fix an arbitrary control of
the market I prime that consists of
values VI Prime and costs CI Prime
and consider the following non-uniform
mechanism
this mechanism ignores the actual Market
I it is facing and only takes the
buyer's budget b as input
it first computes the optimal solution
to the knapsack instance that is
specified by the contrived Market I
Prime and the budget b
then it offers each seller I in the
knapsack optimal solution a ticket or
leave payment CI Prime
although this mechanism is silly because
it doesn't care about the actual marked
eye it is facing
it's trivially useful in the budget
visible
there is no way we can compare to this
mechanism on instance that is specified
by I Prime and patched B
much
now I wanted to State our first main
result
we designed a randomized mechanism that
is almost as good as any uniform
mechanism on every property instance
moreover we examine our randomized
mechanism in the same empirical setting
as before when we compare the AGM
mechanism and the clock oxygen
namely the items have the same value but
costs are sampled IID from natural
distributions
the results are in this table and we can
see that for single model distribution
both our mechanism and the clock auction
outperforms AGM mechanism by a large
margin
a known multimodal distributions
our mechanism outperforms the other two
mechanisms significantly
our mechanism is very simple
for Simplicity let's again assume every
item I has value 1 but the unknown
coaster
an important notion that's used in our
mechanism is Lottery
specifically Lottery L with parameter as
p1b2t and T is a distribution over two
decades or leave offers namely we offer
the seller a payment P1 for his item
with probability and offer P2 with
probability will minus t
our mechanism is as follows
first we partition all the sellers in
the two buckets X1 and the X2 uniformly
at random then we ask the sellers in X1
to report their costs and the computer
the best Lottery that achieves the
highest expected value on X1 such that
the expected total payment is bounded by
DB divided by 2.
similarly we ask every seller in X2 to
report their cost
and compute the best Lottery L2 that
achieves the highest expected value of
mix 2 such that the expected total
payment is funded by B divided by 2.
finally for every seller in X1 we sample
a payment from Lottery L2 and offer it
to the seller we keep doing this until
we spend the B divided by 2.
and similarly for every seller in X2
with sample payment from the lottery
album
and offer this payment to the seller
and we keep doing this until we spend a
bit divided by two
later I'll show the proof outline of the
optimality of this mechanism against any
uniform mechanism
but now I just want to say
this mechanism is simply useful because
for every seller
the lottery they are facing does not
depend the cost that they report
therefore there is no incentive for them
to cheat
and this mechanism is simply budget
feasible because of the constraint in
the third step
foreign
so far we have seen that worst case
optimality doesn't speak for the average
case performance
and as I explained before instance
optimality is too much too helpful if we
want to compare with no uniform
mechanisms
therefore we proved our instance
optimality result against the uniform
mechanisms
now we strike a reasonable Middle Ground
where we can compare average case
performance with non-uniform mechanisms
specifically we study a
semi-anniversarial model called budget
smooth analysis which was proposed in
our last three years itcs paper
in budget smooth analysis the market I
is the worst case chosen by the
adversary
but as budget b is sampled from a random
distribution
now let me introduce the model of budget
smooth analysis first we fix the budget
distribution D for example the empirical
distribution of buyer's budgets then the
diversary picks a single worst case
Market I arguably there are many buyers
procuring items in the same Market
but they have very different budgets
then we sample random budget b from the
distribution d
and run the mechanism on the instance
that is specified by markdi and the
budget b
the performance measure for mechanism is
it's expected competitive ratio
where the expectation is taken over the
budgeted distribution d
notice that once we fix a budgeted
distribution D then
the budget's most analysis is
essentially a maximum gain between the
mechanism designer and the adversary
where the objective is the expected
competitive ratio first the mechanism
designer chooses best mechanism M and
then the diversary chooses a worst case
Market I
we have the following results for Budget
smooth analysis
first we prove that our randomized
mechanism is optimal in this model
regardless of the budgeted distribution
moreover we give a characterization of
the worst case market for any given
budgeted distribution
and we show that our randomized
mechanism has better than momentum over
e expected competitive ratio for any
non-trivial parts of the distribution
regardless of the market
by non-trivial I mean there are at least
two parts in the support of the budgeted
distribution
in contrast
given any money to rent job budgets we
can construct a single Market where
agents or stress optimal mechanism only
gets one minus one over e competitive
ratio for any budget in the range
which shows the separation
finally we prove a robust hardness
result that says no budget distribution
allows better than
0.854 expected competitive ratio for the
worst case Market
finally I wanted to give an overview of
the proof of our main results first I am
let you talk about the instance
optimality result against the uniform
mechanisms
here is a brief proof outline so first
we prove that for every instance the
optimal uniform mechanism is a lottery
of two text or leave payments
this is by using a greedy exchange
argument
then we prove that our randomized
mechanism can approximate the optimal
uniform mechanism arbitrarily well
this is basically applying concentration
bond in a clever way
now I wanted to talk about the
optimality of our mechanism in budget
smooth analysis
recall that given any budget
distribution D but its Muslim analysis
is essentially a maximum gain between
the mechanism designer and the adversary
once we apply the max theorem this is
equivalent to the following min max
program
given the Mi Max program we first
analyze it with a restriction that the
mechanism is a uniform mechanism
and we give a characterization of the
worst case Market I star of this
restricted Max program
in istar items have equal value
and the CDF of their costs
satisfy the following property
we denote the CDF of worst case Market
istar by F of c and we draw the plot
whereas the x-axis is f of c and the
y-axis is z times F of C we prove that
this curve must be convex
in the second step we show that
by convex the non-uniform mechanism is
no better than the uniform mechanism for
the worst case Market I star
since we have shown that our mechanism
is instance optimal against the uniform
mechanisms
it follows our mechanism is an optimal
mechanism in the restricted members
program from the first step
and by pointer 2
our mechanism is also optimal in the
original mimax program when we bring
back the non-uniform mechanisms
this proves the optimality of our
mechanism in the budget smooth analysis
model
that is all I want to tell you
if you have any question feel free to
reach out to me use an email
and if you are interested in budget's
Muslim analysis and I wanted to know
more about it
please check out the video of our last
year's idcs paper
which is also on YouTube
and finally thanks for watching this
video